Olha só, você sabia que agora 12 por8 de
pressão não é mais normal? Pois é,
mudaram as regras do jogo, isso pode
afetar metade dos brasileiros que
achavam que estavam bem. Veja bem, a
nova diretriz brasileira que baixou a
barra do que é considerado saudável.
Antes 12x8 era tranquilo, agora já é
pré-hpertensão. E não para por aí não. A
meta para quem já tem impressão alta
também mudou de 14 por9 para 13x8, ou
seja, ficou tudo muito mais rigoroso.
Mas calma, vou te falar uma coisa, como
o médico há 28 anos, essa mudança tem
dois lados. Por um lado, sim, vamos
pegar mais cedo quem tá desenvolvendo
hipertensão, isso salva vidas, previne a
ver infarto. Por outro lado, olha só,
vamos transformar milhões de pessoas
saudáveis em pré-doentes, porque 12 por8
não dá sintoma nenhum, a pessoa tá
vivendo normal e aí de repente ela vira
paciente. Para mim isso tem cara de
indústria farmacêutica esfregando as
mãos. Minha opinião, se você tem 12 por8
e nenhum outro fator de risco antes de
entrar em pânico ou tomar remédio,
investe na dieta, no exercício, controla
o estresse. Agora me conta nos
comentários, você acha que isso é
prevenção ou exagero médico?